[Música]
un jurado federal estadounidense declaró
culpables de crimen de odio a los dos
hombres blancos que asesinaron al
afroamericano en wood are very en 2020 y
a uno tercero que lo grabó por este
veredicto podrían recibir otra condena a
cadena perpetua que ya recibieron
anteriormente en una corte estatal
el presidente de colombia e iván duque
se mostró en contra de la
despenalización del aborto hasta la
semana 24 de gestación decisión tomada
este lunes por la corte constitucional
colombiana el mandatario dijo que no se
puede permitir que el aborto se
convierta en un método anticonceptivo
el sur de américa arde en llamas los
incendios en chile argentina y paraguay
tienen en alerta a las autoridades no
solo por los cultivos clave cuya
destrucción tiene impacto en la economía
sino por la calidad del aire
bienvenidos a este nuevo informativo de
france 24 dedicado al continente
americano soy rodrigo sedano y es un
gusto acompañarlos un jurado federal
estadounidense declaró culpables de
crimen de odio motivado por racismo a
los tres hombres blancos implicados en
el asesinato al afroamericano inmutar
ver y barbería hacía ejercicio físico
por un barrio de bruce week en el estado
de georgia cuando fue perseguido y
asesinado por dos de los tres culpables
que ya fueron anteriormente condenados a
cadena perpetua por un homicidio en una
corte estatal el tercero grabó la acción
con su teléfono y esta nueva sentencia
podría sumarles otra condena a cadena
perpetua y multas escuchemos las
palabras de la madre de la víctima y
obtuvimos una victoria hoy pero hay
tantas familias que no juguetes que no
tienen victoria es debido a las personas
que tenemos luchando por nosotros el
presidente de colombia iván duque se
pronunció en contra de la decisión de la
corte suprema de justicia de
despenalizar el aborto hasta la semana
24 estación algunos sectores
conservadores e incluso médicos
consideran que la legalización fue
permitida hasta un estado demasiado
avanzado de la gestación veamos más en
el informe de amal benotman el
presidente de colombia iván duque se
mostró contra la decisión de la corte
constitucional de despenalizar la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
hasta los 6 meses de gestación y por
cualquier motivo yo creo que aquí
realmente estamos ante una decisión que
atañe a toda la sociedad colombiana y
cinco personas no pueden
plantearle a una nación algo tan a toros
como permitir que se interrumpa una vida
hasta los seis meses de gestación yo
creo que esas son las discusiones que
hoy tenemos que asumir como país el
mandatario agregó que no se puede
permitir que el aborto se convierta en
un método anticonceptivo pero al
contrario de lo que afirma los estudios
muestran que colombia logró un amplio
conocimiento y uso de la anticoncepción
aunque algunas mujeres especialmente las
que viven en las zonas remotas del país
siguen teniendo a menudo problemas el
uso efectivo de los métodos
anticonceptivos lo que conduce a
embarazos no deseados mientras tanto las
mujeres colombianas recibieron la
decisión del tribunal supremo con la
alegría y alivio estoy de acuerdo y
estoy muy feliz en el corazón no me cabe
tanta felicidad de que de ahora en
adelante nosotros vamos a poder decidir
como si queremos o no ser madres
antes la interrupción voluntaria del
embarazo se permitía en algunos casos
concretos como la violación en la salud
de la madre o una malformación del feto
colombia se convierte así en el quinto
país latinoamericano en flexibilizar las
condiciones de acceso al aborto tras
argentina uruguay cuba y guyana en medio
de la crisis penitenciaria en ecuador el
presidente guillermo lasso firmó un
decreto para disminuir el hacinamiento
en las prisiones el mandatario afirmó
que aspira a que cinco mil presos salgan
de la cárcel además presentó el lunes un
proyecto para transformar el sistema con
enfoque de derechos humanos como
respuesta a la profunda crisis que en
2021 generó enfrentamientos entre bandas
de reos por el control de las prisiones
que dejaron unos 300 reclusos muertos
el relator especial de las naciones
unidas para la independencia de jueces y
abogados diego garcía sayán pidió a
bolivia garantizar la salud de la ex
presidenta interina jeanine áñez que
actualmente lleva 14 días en huelga de
hambre que inició al margen del reinicio
del juicio en su contra recordemos que
áñez está próxima a cumplir un año en
prisión preventiva acusada de supuesta
sedición conspiración y terrorismo en
medio de la crisis tras las elecciones
de 2019
el estado frente a cualquier persona
privada de libertad es el responsable de
la integridad física y de la salud de
las personas que están en esa condición
y que por supuesto en todos los casos
incluidos el de dejar engaño es en la
medida
por supuesto respetando todas las
garantías procesales y las normas del
debido proceso el presidente paraguayo
mario abdo benítez destituyó a su
ministro del interior- arnaldo giuzzio
por supuestos vínculos con el
narcotráfico el ahora ex ministro
reconoció haber tenido contacto con el
narcotraficante brasileño marcus
vinícius espíndola marqués de padua
detenido la semana pasada en brásil en
el límite con la frontera paraguaya ya
que le ofreció servicios para una de sus
compañías las autoridades iniciaron una
investigación al respecto
la profunda se cumplieron diez años de
la tragedia ferroviaria en la estación
11 de buenos aires que dejó 52 muertos y
más de 700 heridos en todo este tiempo
las víctimas han luchado judicialmente
por que se reconozcan las
responsabilidades penales en el
accidente se han dictado un total de 21
condenas firmes al maquinista también a
empresarios y funcionarios por delitos
de corrupción ninguno de ellos se
encuentra actualmente en prisión
hay alerta en el sur del continente por
los incendios forestales miles de
hectáreas han sido consumidas por las
llamas en chile argentina y paraguay y
que se han visto agudizados por la
sequía melissa chávez tiene más detalles
tres países del continente se encuentran
en llamas
paraguay argentina y chile- registran
desde el inicio del año grandes
incendios forestales actualmente en la
araucanía chilena las autoridades
locales piden ayuda al gobierno nacional
estamos vividas con 58 incendios activos
en la región de araucanía un número que
no lo hemos tenido durante esta
temporada bastante preocupante en
distintas comunas de la región según la
corporación nacional forestal de chile
cinco sectores se encuentran en alerta
roja y otros tres en alerta amarilla en
lo que va de año se han presentado mil
40 incendios un aumento del 400 63 por
ciento en comparación con la misma
temporada en 2021 paraguay-argentina
tienen el mismo problema la sequía
facilita el avance de los incendios que
dejan hectáreas totalmente arrasadas mi
esposo quedó sin nada ni una casa todo
se quemó todo todo lo que tenemos
la nueva gamer todos actualmente en
argentina en la provincia de corrientes
están desplegados 159 brilla y ocho
aviones cuatro helicópteros y se suman a
las labores 70 funcionarios forestales
provenientes de bolivia mientras que en
paraguay se teme el gran impacto en la
agricultura se estima unos 3000 millones
de dólares en pérdidas para este año por
la reducción en las cosechas en un 60%
la patagonia chilena posee la mayor
superficie de glaciares de sudamérica
expertos señalan que el aumento en las
temperaturas está generando el deshielo
en los glaciares de la región de aysén
dennis herrera nos comparte la historia
[Aplausos]
el calentamiento global ha llegado a uno
de los lugares recónditos del mundo a la
patagonia chilena a la apartada región
de aysén en la zona austral del país al
sur de esta región se ubica la zona de
campos de hielo considerada la tercera
masa glacial más extensa del planeta
tras la antártida y groenlandia según la
unidad de glaciología y nieves de chile-
la altura del glaciar ha disminuido 80
metros desde 1944 que podemos calcular
tasas de descenso y esas tasas de ss nos
dicen que el promedio en este glaciar
que se está descendiendo del orden de 0
70 8 metros por año la inmensa masa de
hielo se podía ver hace años a la media
hora de entrar al parque nacional laguna
san rafael el más grande de esta región
hoy hay que caminar tres horas para
llegar al hielo y reposo de la mayor
superficie de glaciares de la región
está distribuido en alrededor de 23 mil
kilómetros cuadrados de hielo
los expertos chilenos explican que el
retroceso en los glaciares se debe a una
única causa a diferencia de otros
lugares en el mundo donde el carbono
negro y hollín o el polvo industrial
provocan el deshielo efecto del cambio
climático en forma más pura porque es
solo el efecto del calentamiento y no el
efecto de la constelación por otra
fuerte antropogénica los expertos
señalan también que el deshielo agravará
la sequía que vive chile desde hace más
de 13 años ya que estas reservas de agua
nutren los ecosistemas
hasta aquí este repaso informativo les
invitamos a seguir conectados con
nosotros en france24 y ampliar toda la
información en nuestro sitio web
france24 puntocom
[Música]